by way of the state of uh new jersey uh
to wisconsin
to the national football league i guess
that's again the rondain root now i'm
missing other people
too um melvin gordon melvin gordon
okay but he didn't yeah that's pretty
much it yeah there's more
there's more but jonathan taylor
indianapolis colts rookie here on the
rich hissing show how are you jonathan
i'm doing well i'm doing well how about
yourself i'm fine so i guess the the
question uh is what exit are you from
jonathan i'm exit one baby at the end
oh wow are you talking like delaware
water gap is that what you're saying
way down there yes sir yeah exit one so
southern new jersey which is part what
part delaware part
pennsylvania all put it all together
that's where you're you got that working
yep okay sir let me ask this question
so what is the wisconsin hold in the
state of new jersey with running backs
what's going on with that
what's up with that it must be something
in the water
i don't it must be some type of you know
gravitational pull
towards wisconsin i couldn't tell you
what it is who else recruited you
jonathan um so i was recruited by
rutgers
virginia tech boston college
um a few ivy league schools and
i mean it was tough it was definitely a
tough choice especially when you get a
chance to
to go ivy league and you know you have
people in year you know
you like the league you'll be set for
life on the other hand you definitely
want to test your abilities against some
of the best players in the nation
but you still want to have a great great
education to fall back on so
i just felt like the university of
wisconsin that was the place for me
to do both of those things right um
did you think of me jonathan when you
were rampaging against the wolverines
even for a split second
i'm just making this about me but you
know i've we've had conversations before
but uh you're one of those you and you
and dobbins are people i'm very pleased
to have no longer in the big ten i'll be
very honest with you
[Laughter]
should i by the way i should have the
the jj watt uh mug
here on the desk you want to go get it
for me chris just to give pay homage to
you
yes this is the mug that uh i had to i
had to drink from
uh thanks to you um jonathan not gonna
lie
uh because this is the mug that he uh he
said that i would have to drink from
when uh
when has he put it wisconsin was beating
michigan here it's chris brockman
bringing it over right here
uh yep this is you uh for competing you
know he's on it
in a wisconsin badger uniform uh
wisconsin 35 michigan 14 final score
uh i think you had something to do with
that jonathan so thank you
that is funny yes oh yes it says this
cup holds rich eisen's tears
um is what it says sorry about that one
it's okay you know what you don't have
to say you're sorry when you're really
not you're just a nice guy i appreciate
it
so uh my gosh your dream of making the
nfl is coming true but never
in a pandemic what has it been like for
you since uh hearing your name on draft
night
um a few months ago jonathan
so really now it's about it's really
just about
trying to play catch-up in a sense
um you know you usually go to rookie
mini camp and you have those on sale
reps you have that on field coaching
so now it's about trying to accelerate
your learning accelerate your play
during camp without having those
previous reps that
any other normal rookie class would have
and i think that you know this
organization's done a great job as far
as
the zoom meetings that we had in between
the time of
draft day to come into camp in order to
get as familiar as possible with the
playbook
so that you don't have to focus on less
of what to do and you can focus on more
how to do it while you're in camp and i
think they did a great job at doing that
and that's what i'm doing now is i'm
trying to accelerate my play my learning
um just because my first time getting
actual on sale reps was on camp
that's right and so who's been helping
you in that process walk me through the
jonathan taylor team team uh that's been
uh
sort of your safety net in that regard
so
definitely it's been marlin but also
rosie nix as well
um as far as the professionalism of it
um you know he's going into
fifth sixth fifth or sixth year and you
know
actually one day i was leaving and he
you know he mentioned to me he's like
you know
clean your locker up and i didn't really
think of it
as much you know i'm just okay let me
clean my locker it is a little messy
and then after i cleaned it up you know
he kind of started talking to me about
how
you want to be a professional you know
you clean your locker up you lay
everything out for the next day so when
you come
in the next morning you don't have to
scramble and look for anything
everything's already laid out and that's
part of being a professional so
definitely marlon uh and rosie mix has
definitely been two guys who've been
helping me a lot as far as getting me up
to speed
and um your your position coach knows
how to uh run over people
from his time in the national football
league do you know who the running backs
coach in
indianapolis is chris i don't tom
rathman okay i heard
him he can run some people over right
jonathan
oh i mean the the guy was one of the
most physical players
ever i mean you watch his tape i mean
you can you can just feel it
in the passion in his voice when he's
coaching us and he's talking about being
physical and he's talking about playing
pound i mean you know that's what he
loves to do
and i think you know just me coming here
was kind of
just perfect because i'm a guy i like to
play physical i like to play between the
tackles um but you know i also like to
you know get on the edge sometimes so
being able to team up with coach rathman
and have him
pour that knowledge in on me i mean he
knows championship football i mean he's
been there
he's won it so he knows what it takes to
be a championship
uh a champion of a player so i
definitely try to soak in as much
information
as i can from that jonathan taylor
indianapolis colts running back rookie
running back here on the rich eisen show
and you also have some special people
um uh in the huddle with you i want to
walk
a couple through with uh with you as
well uh philip rivers
um he's got he's got something uh this
season
uh to i guess to prove despite uh a
decade and a half plus in the nfl with
distinction
he doesn't curse uh you know that
jonathan right he doesn't ever swear
you're aware of that correct okay is
that what is it uh
dad gummit gosh dern i mean and that's
real
that's real that's uh that's very very
real uh you don't curse do you jonathan
it's okay if you do
no you don't sir so that's two so we're
we're not working blue
in the in the huddle is what you're
saying
no no i mean and i think just to have a
guy like that
you know a leader like you think of
someone leader who has fire who has
passion
who's not afraid to you know sometimes
you know let their emotions go let it
run wild to let everybody know how
passionate they feel
philip rivers does the same thing um but
without you know you know kind of vulgar
language
as such and you know when you have a guy
like that who's able to show that
emotion
show that passion and still have you
know a sense of restraint still be able
to control himself and
you know in certain ways i think that's
that's the kind of leader that you want
and
i think that's really good yeah and then
um protecting him and blowing open holes
for you is one of the best
uh and nastiest uh quentin nelson his
his film
is the stuff of legend i'm wondering
what it's like to see him uh
up close and personal so far for you
jonathan i mean it's been awesome
working with him i mean just and just
his kind of
passion as far as wanting to get the
right fit
wanting to take the right course you
know asking us hey you know
how is that course how was that fit i
mean was that a good fit for you and
you know whenever you have you know
office alignment you know asking you you
know
how was you know their fit how was their
execution of their job i mean
it just makes it that much more fun
because you know that they're in it
you're into it and you are you all want
to make the the best choices for each
other
um you know but he's a jersey guy so you
know jersey guys work hard oh
that's right he is a jersey guy what
exit is he from do we know
he's so he's from up north i i don't
know i mean that might be
what city he might be up the turnpike he
might be at the turnpike
okay so what what's the city we can
figure that out uh holmdel
home dinner let's see like uh one third
well again it's again he's talk if we're
talking turnpike that's probably like
exit 10. yeah i think that's like an
exit 10 turnpike
i'm trying to recall because my parents
used uh i'll tell you my my parents
lived in marlborough new jersey for many
many years
the garden state art center it's off the
parkway
okay off the parkway yeah very good one
by the way
we're turning into waze all of a sudden
right now with jonathan taylor
trying to figure out all the different
things so cali it's the new jerseyans
instead of the episode of the
californians from from snl
yeah he's he's really good man and so
okay part of me
is just genuinely you know rooting for
you and concerned and part of me wants
to give my my listeners and viewers a
little bit of fantasy information how
many touches are you expecting to get
jonathan taylor
in 2000
we don't even talk about that i mean one
of the i know one thing we do talk about
is we talk about
uh you know especially i talk to marlon
about it a lot is you know what does it
take to
to be you know a guy at this level um
because you know that's all we all want
to be
everyone in everyone in the back room
wants to be a guy every time they step
on the field they want people to know
like hey
make sure you check this number because
if he gets the ball in his hands we got
to make sure that we're on our a game
because he can make something happen so
being able to just pick his brain and
you know
whatever things that he see things that
he does on the field
he's coming off the side i'm like hey
what did you see there i mean what what
made you do that what made you think of
this
being able to pick his brain is
something that i'm gonna keep doing
something i've been doing and
i can't wait to see where it takes us
this year see i know you know i i
shouldn't have just come straight
through the front door with somebody as
smart as you jonathan so i'll try this
i'll try this what are your personal
goals for 2020 what are your personal
goals well done
thank you thank you jonathan taylor oh
definitely definitely this year i want
to
do the most that i can in order to you
know be able to step in that field and
have
not any minor no mental errors um
you know one thing chris talks about is
a guy who stays in this league is a guy
who's a great football player
consistently
um that's the way you stay in this uh
this league
and i want to be consistent and that's
something i tried to do in college and i
still want to do that and it's even more
important now
at this level because consistency is
everything
well you were consistent in your two
answers so here's repeat after me
jonathan taylor
i want a thousand thousand repeat after
me say those words
oh i mean everybody yeah everybody would
win a thousand thousand who would have
won a thousand thousand that was
like the amazing ten touchdowns eighty
catches i mean i'm feeling you let's go
that would be amazing if you could do
that rook a year
uh have you reached out to melvin gordon
is is there a
wisconsin running back group of some
sort or
james white is out there as well he's we
all know he's uh
he's a super bowl champion have you have
you reached that at all
i i definitely talked to melvin gordon i
mean and he actually he reached out to
me and told me i know he kind of
you know knows the protections um a bit
because
you know the staff part of the staff has
come over from san diego
um you know for the rivers the oc
um so you know melvin was a part of that
so
in between that period between draft day
and then zoom meetings
he was just going to me telling me kind
of things that i should expect with this
kind of
offense certain things that i should
expect so him being able to help me out
but also given his insight as far as
listen
you know at this level make sure that
you're able to do your job you know your
playbook that's going to be one of the
biggest things
is knowing your playbook because
anything could be dialed up at any time
and then outside of football uh jonathan
have you and the cults
had a comfab about jacob blake the the
gentleman in the state of wisconsin who
is now um
currently uh in the hospital after being
shot in the back seven times
um yeah i mean have you had a
conversation about
obviously social justice in any way
shape or form in recent days
we've done that in the in the off season
but we also have
just done it today and you know we just
kind of re
emphasized that we're going to be at the
forefront we're going to be at
the spearhead of this this movement i'm
going into this season
and you know we definitely won't be
silent um but like i said we're gonna be
at the forefront and we're gonna do
everything on our power
in order to continue raise awareness
have these conversations and promote
change
no obviously jonathan i i know again i'm
asking a rookie who's got a lot on his
plate it's a pandemic your dreams are
coming
true you want to succeed and to throw
this um
uh you know on your plate as well is is
is a lot but
is there a way that you what can you
share about the conversations that
everybody had
uh within your your locker room today as
you mentioned
on this subject of course
a lot of opinions as far as you know
what people thought but also
you get a lot of people sharing their
experiences of things that
they've experienced throughout their
lifetimes and
it even it everyone learns no matter who
you are
you know when you're having those
conversations everyone learns something
no matter who who you are and i think
that's the biggest thing is
you may even think and i don't know
anybody who does but you could probably
think yeah i know
quite a bit about it as far as you know
things that have gone on in the past and
throughout history but when someone
shares an experience with you that
they've had
and you're able to sit there face to
face with them and see that emotion on
their face
hear it feel it it changes you it moves
something inside of you and it makes you
it makes you want to go out there and
continue to be part of that change to
continue to promote change because
these are real people these are real
life situations happening and it's not
going to go away unless you know people
take a stand and
you know have these conversations that's
one of the many reasons why i like
having you on
jonathan and that i root for you despite
you
destroying uh a handful of falls for me
in the college football world is you are
a real person
you're a person you can tell you you
know that you're a real person
with a head on your shoulders and a
heart in your chest and
um and and a great desire to be great
and i wish you nothing but the best i
truly do and i hope
there's many times that we get to talk
this fall
thank you very much rich i appreciate
that thank you right back at you all
right well the pride of uh
of exit one right and that's the parkway
correct that's the garden state parkway
it's the parkway okay
not the because i i went exit one of the
of the turnpike
and by the way james white's from
florida i i but he went to wisconsin i
know that
i thought he's i thought only garden
staters are allowed to run the ball
from them and make the nfc you can ball
you can ball
that's it and uh you can do that thanks
for the call jonathan you take care of
yourself
thank you very much rich i appreciate
you having me on right back at you let's
stay in touch that's jonathan taylor